so as a poet as a writer I've written a
book a poetry but not working a new book
what can you say
about your process of crafting words I
think people listening to this can can
hear that there's a poetry the way you
speak in English
so
somebody that cares about
the craftsmanship of words in both
English and Arabic what can you say
about your process
uh it's a lot more neat than like this
conversation it's like I am obsessed
with with sentences and it takes me a
long time to like
finish a piece of writing I'm I I'm a
perfectionist do you edit a lot I I did
all the time and I like can't move on
from one sentence until it's perfect but
I will say my other writer friends here
in New York do not face
is how
easily disrupted my writing as by other
news
any all picture stories on my editor
about something for example and then as
I'm writing it
20 minutes and some kid was shot and
killed by the Israeli military so you
have to say something about it and then
30 minutes later as I'm writing it
there's news about a home demolition in
silhouan and there is this Relentless
um onslaught of news that prevents us
and depresses of the ability to analyze
to frame to think to conceptualize to
you know to write beyond the current
affairs were stuck in this in the
relentlessness of the occupation
that a lot of the time I worry that the
the things I'm writing are always in
reaction to a crime that took place to a
a bombing that took place and so on and
so forth and I think that's
unfortunately true for so many
Palestinian writers so
you know
I would say isolation and like stepping
away from the news is very important
um to do but I don't do it
so okay so the the struggled to find the
time that the Timeless message in it is
uh an ongoing struggle for you I mean
there is there is the the Timeless you
know it's not even timelessness it's
Timeless I think what what you write is
always timely because the occupation is
ongoing but the struggle is you know
moving beyond the news and tackling more
nuances
um because my in Arabic I can in Arabic
I can philosophy as I can talk about
violence then I can talk about my
complicated relationship with violence
or like my complicated I can complicate
and nuance and give things Nuance but in
English people still do not believe we
are under occupation even though it is
an internationally recognized fact that
is broadcasted 24 7 to the world's most
watched screens so we're stuck in like a
practice of providing facts and figure
as in actually this happened and and
this person did this and and according
to international law and blah blah blah
so we're stuck in this because of the
basic truths about our own existence are
denied that we don't even have the
luxury of you know
evolving or rating Beyond it or at least
evolving my writing Beyond it and this
is what I'm trying to do with this
notebook
that's fascinating that in English
you're
uh your brain is more inclined to be
to go towards activism or is in Arabic
you have the luxury to be more a
philosopher I wouldn't say activism I
would say journalism like just uh just
making sure you know like disrupting the
flow of the sentence to insert uh a
statistic or insert uh a historical fact
that should be employed yeah and should
be a household name but it's not
um you know
I can't just say the nakaba I have to
say the nakaba the 1948 total near total
Destruction of fasting Society at the
hands of Zionist militia that leader
formed the Israeli military that now
terrorizes us today and there's like and
there's like three tier legal system
blah blah blah you I can't just say that
but you have to give all of these
explanations
and that's
that's heartbreaking and people are
ought to do better people are out to you
know do better this is not
it's not it's not what my uh literature
should be limited to it's not what
anybody's literature should be looking
to do it's the job of
it's the job of you know news reporters
to reward the news but a lot of the time
to use looted language they use passive
voice the office Cape facts
and it's on the shoulders of us
the heavy carrying would you say the the
president in the in the United States
does a good or poor job of covering
Israel and Palestine terrible job
horrible job what's up they don't do
their job whatsoever what are the
biggest failings not mentioning that a
town is occupied when you're reporting
about an occupied Town not mentioning
that a settlement is illegal or a
settler is illegally present in a
Palestinian Village when you're
reporting on them only quoting
um
Israeli officials and only quoting
Israeli politicians and police officers
and framing your entire analysis with
Israeli officials and only interviewing
Palestinians when they have
um been brutalized and victimized
physically yeah those are some of the
issues there's there is plenty and then
like saying things you know like is
Israel will
um Israel will bomb a hospital in Gaza
and the the Press will say like Hamas
run hospital and this negative
association with Hamas will remove any
sympathy from the reader towards the
victims of this Hospital bombing
um a lot of things and a lot of a lot of
them are Sinister I have many friends
many journalists friends and I've seen
many journalists online speak about
their experiences when talking about
Palestine
um the censorship that goes on into it
um and you have many journalist friends
some at the New York Times some
um
there used to be at the Washington Post
who tell me the kinds of battles they
had to do they had to go through with
their others to let them even utter the
word Palestine
and not even on in like news pieces like
pieces about
let's say a Palestinian artist or a
Palestinian Chef or whatever you know
there's lots of there's there's a lot
that happens behind the scene that is
not reported on
um because when it comes to Palestine
the the rules and the laws of Journalism
are bendable you know passive voice is
King emitting facts is acceptable
Anything Goes